oh snap
we helped you
[Music]
oh did y'all hear how the music changed
right yeah
what's poppin everyone what's goody
everyone welcome aboard
welcome welcome
to our
[Music]
welcome to our feels a little dark in
here
this is our monthly 100 joke contest so
welcome aboard everyone
i'm joel bias
if you didn't know
it feels a little dark in here doesn't
it
something's off i don't think so though
don't know
i don't know maybe the add is already
kicking in
but i will say
as you all are coming in here the
gratitude is kicking in thank y'all for
hanging out with us today
we are going
to do a live
contest for the top three finalists of
our 100 joke contest
we are doing a live finale where we will
play their sets and then you
get to vote
for who wins the 100 bucks and
an interview on hot breath so
good morning we have ed
ed in the building bobby in the building
jack in the building joan good to see
all y'all thanks for commenting
getting that algorithm going
as people come in here how it's gonna
work
we're gonna play each set and then do
voting
on the best set
and then
hey and then they'll come on the show
live and get interviewed
what's up sandy what's goodie
it is very mood like i don't know what
changed though
i think it was missing
because it's usually brighter in the
back right maybe maybe it's the back
see if we can
turn that up
but still
it's like
i don't know
interesting i live stream like three
times a week on here
but then for some reason it looks
different today
that's weird
oh leland in the building good morning
leland
what's up nate what's goody pam bob kirk
says good luck everyone
oh yeah we're about to jump into it my
friends
about to jump into it
we're gonna let the peeps roll in i was
trying to figure out my lighting
it feels
dark and me being dark you know that's
the opposite i'm white
it is why
maybe my screen's dark what if that was
funny what if it was my screen was too
turned down so everything just looked
dark
i don't hate that actually now that i
turned my screen up actually don't hate
that
not bad for diy comedian
all right
evelyn good morning
here we go
we're going to start it people
we're gonna start it
so we're starting the contest
tell your peeps to come in here and vote
for you
or don't and lose so
you guys can share this youtube link
let the peeps know
dino good morning dino say good luck to
all the comics
all right let's get into it i think
we're ready to start here's people
coming in here
ladies and gentlemen
officially
welcome
to the april 100
joke contest
all right as we say here
what's good what is goodie my friends
welcome
to the hundred dollar joke contest every
month
we do this to hook up a comic with a
hundred bucks and an interview on hot
breath
the name of the game is
all these contestants
got
seven days to write a new 90-second set
based on a theme
this month's theme
[Music]
fun
this month's theme was fun
so this was a fun one
to get into
and we're gonna have fun today for
chisel
i'm super excited about these top three
there were several contestants and if
you're like
oh that sounds good i would like to get
paid to write jokes well
all these contestants are graduates of
our comedy writing master class so
all the people that join our comedy
writing master class get access to this
hundred dollar joke contest we do every
month so if that's something you'd be
interested in
just go to hotbreathmedia.com
and we'll see you there
but this
is this month's contest and these
my friends
these rat chairs
where to go
ah
these are your finalists everyone we got
chris beasley nate cosby and jack allen
these are your top three finalists my
friends
so that being said
we're gonna watch each one
and then vote and as you are watching
and as you are voting or whatnot
just watch it from
how funny is it one how on theme is it
so how did they use the theme of fun
to create a unique 90 second set
and then just how funny is it you know
is it funny do they open with a quick
laugh do they close with a laugh do they
have persistent laughs throughout you
know
these are all things you want to keep in
mind as you're watching and voting and
silently judging thinking you could have
done better
hmm
well
you didn't
so there's always next month though
and with that being said
my friends
the running order we are gonna do we are
gonna do chris beasley
and we're gonna do jack allen
then we're gonna close it out with mr
nate cosby everyone so it's going to be
a goodie in the hoodie of a hootin
anytime
it's going to be goody
for shizzle
so if there aren't any questions we are
going to start
start
the show
cool beans savvy comics says good luck
and it is time my friends so first
up
in the april
hundred dollar joke contest
first up
is mr chris beasley my friends
so as i like to say here
all
on this show
let's get ready to rumble
[Applause]
first comic cop
chris beasley
anytime my wife says fun i end up with a
to-do list let's have a picnic it'll be
fun just go to target buy us drinks
sandwiches lots of chocolate spring
bouquet of flowers and a wicker basket
wait how about you hand weave that
basket knit us a blanket to sit on and
buy a private island it'll be fun
every time my wife says fun a bank
teller dies and my man run me the money
my wife has a day off
my wife just wants to have an adventure
do i look like huckleberry finn i'm 30.
i want to have an advil
my wife just wants to do white people
[__] i can't do that anymore she's like
let's go bungee jumping
bungee jumping you mean you want to tie
a rope to a black man
drop them let them hang
and then make them pay for it hell no
that's racist hey my man have you ever
had a karen make you fund your own hate
crime yeah i ain't think so my wife's
like let's go mountain climbing you
don't even mount me what is this the x
games keep playing these games you're
gonna end up my ex my wife's like let's
go bike riding getting there will be
half the fun
getting there is half the fun only
applies to orgasms if i'm doing all this
work what time am i getting off my wife
says my kind of fun is tongue-in-cheek
yeah that's how you eat ass
i'm always telling my wife like hey
let's get the baby making black lives
matter black lives matter she thinks i'm
always protesting but really my hand is
stuck in this position because carpal
tunnel is fun
yeah
all right chris beasley
there's the first one
first one
mr chris beasley well done there chris
what did y'all think of chris there
what do you all think of chris
oh all the applause sound effects coming
in
a lot of good word play there
x games are gonna end up my ex a lot of
good a lot of good fun writing there
sound like he was in a confessional
didn't it sounded like he was like
hiding in his car from his family to
yell about his family is what it sounded
like
but
what matters most
is it funnier gnaw
and that was funny for sure
why isn't the chair going oh wait that
is not the chair
my chair just went down did y'all see
that
i hit the wrong button i was trying to
get to lean back
because it's not leaning back
oh there it is all right
now we're cooking
yeah there we go all right
oh ed said loved getting to orgasm
for sure yeah
that's so weird to
then read
back on live here loved getting to
orgasm
everyone said oh i loved your phone your
own hate grime and the expressions are
perfect jack said great job chris
sandy oh so many great punch lines i
don't even know where to begin
she liked the bungee jump analogy
oh jones said it was great so many good
bits nate said way to go chris
i like this the two contestants jack and
nate are like yeah yeah good job they're
not like i don't want to gash you up too
much
saying a specific thing i liked
but
we'll say way to go
good job
and i like it i like it keep it close to
the vest gents because this is for a
hundred bucks that's a lot of money
a hundred dollars a hundred dollars
do you know how many gallons of gas you
could get for that um
oh yeah bungee jumping dino like the
bungee jumping and so did bobby yeah
that was a great analogy there chris we
came out swinging
we came out swinging
shouty
we came out swinging fam we came out
swinging and i'm not talking like this
just to talk like this i'm talking like
this
because the stakes are high
i was literally about to say i'm talking
like this but not because chris is black
but then i realized that me just saying
the word black is triggering to people
um
i i just look triggering at this point
but
it's not because chris i can't even say
black people get uncomfortable
they're like oh my gosh he better say
lives matter after that
oh we are canceling him on his own show
all
right
leland liked the bungee jumping as well
very nice
nicely done there thanks for sharing
there leland yeah yeah yeah i love that
love people sharing their feedback on
what they liked
but meow
we have two more my friends chris did
well but
don't go to voting yet there's two more
coming in hot
and the next we have
is mr jack allen are you all ready for
jack allen out there are you all ready
for jack
[Music]
let's hear it
yeah and sandy said i didn't think
chris could top himself but this is the
best one yet whoa chris whoa
look at you mr fancy pants
all right
here we go my friends
bobby's ready for jack all right
well here we go
ladies and gentlemen
it's time
for
your next contestant
i feel like i'm on the price is right
it's mr jack allen my friends
welcome
jack allen
i'm sorry i feel like i'm talking choppy
but i'm having technical difficulties
over here
um
so i was trying to talk through them
talking to you while my add is trying to
figure out
the technical difficulty while gassing
up your next contestant
which we're ready ladies and gentlemen
the next coming up
mr jack allen
oh that's nate
no
oh
my gosh
all right
we're gonna take two on that
yo last month's
contest live stream went so smooth
and this one's going smoothish you know
like a smooth criminal
we're ready baby
next up
jack allen
here we go
[Music]
summer fun in the garden or as my
parents call it how i was
conceived
but i'm free of emotional scarring
unlike the garden daffodils
now my fun as a teenager came from group
job interviews oh yes
a punishment for the mass unemployed
so
jake
jack jack
what makes you think you'd be a good fit
for us at tesco's superstore
well brenda i just have this burning
passion for
night shifts and minimum wage
i see
okay and what are your goals for the
coming year
oh
that's tough but i'd have to say
definitely
losing my virginity
and just think brenda with the aid of
your corporation i'll be able to take a
female out on a date without my card
rejecting yes
fun for me now
is judging my neighbors recycling boxes
oh three bottles of vodka
now we know how janet's been dealing
with her divorce huh
now i'm 27. it's time for my bev fun in
the garden
huh jack
are you gonna mow this lawn or what
yes
coming mom
oh boy
we're cooking now baby give it up for
jack allen everyone huh
going through his neighbor's recycling
oh my gosh i love that
i love that
that's really not janet's divorce
oh and bobby liked your glasses there
jack maybe you got some merch
maybe jack got some merch game on fleek
shawty
oh nate said great job jack
jack allen i stole it from my mom
hilarious
oh
look at all of us in here
sandy said coming mom lol
evelyn burning passion for night shift
and minimum wage yeah for sure i love
that line too ed great job jack love the
recycling bit i really
yeah i really like the recycling bit
there's a lot of good ones in there but
that
just rummaging through and putting the
glasses on was very funny
hilarious
nice job jack all the way from across
the pond
jack
bringing the heat and relating to bobby
bobby now feels understood because she
goes through her neighbor's recycling as
well
leland liked the recycling bit
jones said the interview was terrific
bob group interview nice glasses
oh man yeah
do you know that was funny stuff jack
well nicely done jack omg
omg look at all that love coming in
well
we're going to keep the love coming in
but
we have one more contestant
my friends
now the first two people
have been in the finals before
they've won before
but
this final contestant
a newbie
and we love seeing that in this contest
i love seeing new people participating
in the contest i love seeing new people
just getting out of their comfort zone
and
actually competing in this because i can
i mean
it sounds easy on the surface
oh a 90 second set just based on this
theme that's easy and then when you sit
down and try to write a 90-second set in
a week
and then you try to rehearse and record
that in a week doing 50 takes like
it's a lot of work and it takes a lot so
the people that actually did submit i
greatly appreciate it and what i love
about this contest is people get new
material out of it
whether they win or not
everyone that competes ends up with new
material that they can do on stage so
that's the name of the game here just
helping comics level up
oh nice steve said i just came in so
whoever goes last is the best in my book
well all right he's our newcomer
the one going up last here is our
newcomer
and his name is nate cosby everyone so
give it up for nate
oh and chris
liked how you were conceived there jack
very nice
but
save it
because we have one more before we vote
here
this is a newbie
and his name
is mr nate cosby
prepare yourselves hot breath verse
my life has become very mundane as of
late my therapist says i need to have
more fun i wasn't sure what i should do
for fun so he suggested i try something
i used to do for fun as a kid
so i dug through the closet pulled out
my old high school baseball bat
walked next door and smashed my
neighbor's mailbox
then i went down to the playground
hopped on the merry-go-round
smoked a joint
on my way home i went to the mall and
stole a lincoln park cd
i asked my girlfriend what i should do
for fun she said
i know
you should start a project
i said what do you think you are
no my girlfriend is a cool chick she has
her own idea of fun
she likes to go to the shooting range so
that last joke is the only one i'm going
to tell about her
she has a nine-year-old boy all he ever
does is play on his vr headset his idea
of fun is entirely escaping the realm of
reality
uh i do something similar but i don't
need a headset because i'm old enough to
just do drugs
my younger brother had a suggestion for
me he said some people find it fun to
research their family history and
genealogy
after relentlessly calling him a dweeb
for two days straight i decided it might
be fun after all so i submitted my dna
sample to ancestry.com
not because i'm interested in genealogy
but because i wanted to see if anyone in
my direct family would get busted for a
cold case homicide
and that's how uncle brian got 28 years
in macalester
come to think of it my life is way more
fun than his
oh boy give it up
give it up
nate cosby everyone nate
cosby
what y'all like about
nate's set there
oh bobby said this set is brilliant
whoa whoa wee wow
oh that's great
loving the big burns who do you think
you are chris liked that too he said
what do you think you are
sandy liked the shooting range joke gary
said awesome had me rolling what's up
what's goody gary
leland like the new guy leland said
great set there
very nice
oh ed said great job nate love the
shooting range joke
joan there were so many good bits from
beginning to end
jack said great set nate evelyn
what do you think you are he killed very
nice said dang i'm late
you are but you're not too late to hang
out and participate my friend
welcome aboard
so those of you
that may or may not know
if you look right here
in the youtube live chat
we have the poll going on
where you see it up here in the live
chat i think y'all can see that see the
voting going on
right here
so far we have 14 votes so far it's nate
in the lead now this is a tight
this is a tight race now i mean
a lot of good sets here
because i mean it's
it's the finals all right it's the
finals
oh nate said thank you everyone bobby
said finally a cosby and comedy we can
openly love
hilarious
[Music]
bob said funny sets to all congrats
leland said nate killed it dino great
job nate i'm glad i'm not your neighbor
funny ride though
yeah i'm glad you're not jack allen's
neighbor either rummaging do your
recycling
hey
eight
so we gonna let the votes roll for a
minute we gonna let the votes roll for a
minute
[Music]
cool beans
oh cool
oh great gary said great job guys this
was fun so close when i need a recount
hilarious
oh and kyle good to see you buddy thanks
for participating
by saying i look hungover hey how about
you come on live
in hd
every single week
three times a week and you look perfect
every time hiding in your pajamas in
your parents basement
vaping on cheerios
hater
i'm not hungover i'm actually sober
since january
oh hater
oh nikki said great job nate that's so
nice
yeah that's what we like here positivity
not lazy roasting about someone
looking hung over
kyle
oh
how brave we are from behind
a screen name
kyle parker i'll dox you right now kyle
i'll pull up your next door
all right we're gonna let the votes roll
for just another minute here
hey
and then
when the winner is announced we're
actually going to bring them on live
for an interview
ain't that fancy
but no i'm not hungover but i am tired
i've actually been
been doing shows and it's just so late
but yeah
you're welcome kyle for even getting up
and doing this yeah
geez
i'll bring that up in my zoom therapy
session next time i'm sober but they
said i look hungover should i quit again
yep
it's always easy from afar
everybody can always look and see what
other people need to do but what about
yourself
everybody has the answers for everyone
but themselves
oh cgm sound said the last person was
very funny yes that was nate
and if we are to look at the votes
i mean
it's looking like
check it out
man
first timer
nate nate nate nate cosby
nate nate nate cosby it looks like yo
first timer
out the gate
nate cosby it sounds like he's our
winner everyone give it up for nate
wow
first timer coming in here swinging and
that goes to show you all
watching this
it's not too late don't be scared
come on in the water's fine
we're gonna bring nate on live to talk
about how he wrote this game winning set
in just in just a moment
and just i'm gonna send you the link
nate cosby
gonna gonna gonna gonna i just sent it
to you on facebook that nate where you
can just click that link
oh chris said congrats nate bob congrats
nate nice one we need the boys in the
hood joke nate
says leland
and as nate is coming in here
if you want to participate
in a future
100 joke contest
all you got to do is join our comedy
writing masterclass and you get
automatically entered every single month
and i will share the link
in
the live chat here i just pinned it to
the top to go to hotbreathmedia.com
is how you can join
but nate convincingly won i mean and he
was going up against him
you know
he was going up against some
you knows some past winners
like multiple time winners
so
we ain't we ain't tripping right here
shouty
steve said congrats drinks on nate
joan congrats nate ed congratulations
nate great job
chris and jack thank you ed
bobby said congratulations nate congrats
to jack and
chris as well all sets were fire yeah
yeah gary great set nate well done
definitely saved the best for last oh
and jack said it was a great set and
thoroughly deserved well good for you
nate
good for you my friend
hey
it was well deserved
so we are about to get
nate in here
nate's in the green room he's putting
his makeup on
oh this is so exciting
oh sandy said you all brought it
congrats nate yeah i mean
the competition was high and thanks to
everyone who did submit
i know even people who just participate
and don't win or get into the finals
they still get a lot out of it i saw
sandy say earlier
she used past contest submissions
when she had to do 30 minutes of clean
material for the parkinson's foundation
whoa that i love
i got it was like that's like a little
subtle brag
it's like yeah this contest helped me
with this amazing gig that i booked
because i'm amazing
that was a nice little little flex there
on the sly though like yeah i love this
contest because i'm awesome
nicely done there sandy i i like that i
like that
very well done
so we're about to bring nate in here my
friends but first let's record the intro
prepare yourselves
what is goodie hot breath verse welcome
back to hot breath the show where you
learn comedy from the pros i am your
host comedian joel byers
and we are taking a break from our
author series to bring in the winner of
this month's hundred dollar joke contest
every single month graduates of our
comedy master class compete for a
hundred bucks and an interview
on hot breath podcasts so this month's
winner our first time participant
is bringing the heat
in this interview
unlike this intro i'm quitting i'm gonna
quit comedy i'm done
forget it
i lost interest in the intro and then i
just lost it
i'm gonna go back to enterprise
rent-a-car i got on live today just to
announce that i'm officially quitting um
i'm going back to enterprise rent-a-car
where i can
wash cars in a tie instead of bomb on
zoom in a tie
looking hungover i love how that's what
sticks with me
all right
let's just bring them in here ladies and
gentlemen
i'm glad i didn't compete in this one
because i would have bombed but ladies
and gentlemen give it up
where'd he go
there he is
there he is oh my gosh it's nate cosby
everyone
hey joel
what's up
how's it going
it's going well how are you doing
i'm doing super uh yeah a hundred
dollars more super my friend did not
expect to win that but you didn't expect
to win
of course i expected to win joel
[Laughter]
dude i mean it was it was well deserved
i love
because my wife and i will watch all
these sets
so we always are like getting excited
we're like oh it's someone new
participating and then out the gate you
won fam
it's the second time i submitted i
submit the last month's submission was
the very first one i think it went a
little bit too long i think i had about
a minute 45 and i was like maybe i can
get away with this last month
but obviously you're not
but
i'm glad i'm glad and then i had a lot
of fun i have a lot of fun with your
writing prompts
yeah so
yeah i have uh
i so much fun so that i have my
girlfriend now uh on the on the weeks
that i don't have a writing prompt from
you i make her give me a writing prompt
so i'm doing a new writing prompt every
week whoa
that's how i just keep on writing
yeah how did you approach this one how
did you approach you got the theme of
fun so then what do you do next
yeah you know i i sort of i remember uh
from your master class like the sort of
the the the joke filters like how you
you run
uh every idea through certain filters
and one of my favorites is the uh
the
how would this
how would this uh happen in in the past
like yeah yeah like a timeline yeah yeah
yeah
so the very first joke that's how i did
like oh i want to have uh okay fun so
what would i do what did i used to do
for fun you know what i mean
um and you know that's how the first
joke came came about you know and from
there
honestly this whole thing was was
written in a matter of like probably the
first two days of the week like monday
and tuesday of that week but by the end
of tuesday i was like i'm pretty sure i
got this
oh wow that quick
yeah it came really quickly to me
so you you wrote it and then but how
many times did you record it
twice
oh nate's a prodigy over here i've
submitted this thing and recorded like
15 times i've like
that was my second take the one that the
one that i submitted oh a little flex
there i see
yeah
what's your favorite joke
uh i'm a big fan of the uh um
the uh
my um my girlfriend uh my girlfriend
likes to go to the shooting range so
that last joke is the only one i'm going
to tell about her
i enjoyed the most
i also like i also liked it
where'd he go did he freeze or did i
freeze
oh gary said i couldn't do this so
respect to all the participants oh gary
you could definitely do it buddy
you could definitely do it
absolutely
all right look like nate had a little
technical difficulty but we're gonna
bring him back in right meow
nate are you there
yeah sorry about that joel i don't know
what happened there no worries no
worries at all my friend i thought i
thought your girlfriend was like all
right that's enough comedy i i want to
hang out
been yelling into this screen all week
yeah
she does have to put up with me talking
into my computer a lot
oh this steve said nate's biggest
strength is that he is
so humble his greatest weakness is that
he is a little too awesome
[Laughter]
no nice i don't know
i'll take that compliment it's better
than looking hung over
hey i'm that too for the record
as he's drinking
[Music]
[Laughter]
i popped the champagne as as soon as i
got them oh a little flex there
look at that a little be easy on a
sunday morning there
sunday it's my only day of the week off
so well congrats man yeah how long you
been doing comedy
i have never even done an open mic i
have not done one open mic but i i am i
am taking
that 90 seconds plus
another 90 seconds that i have prepared
uh to to the comedy club of kansas city
for the open mic on thursday night
and uh that'll be the first that'll be
the first time i do uh stand up this
thursday
it's thursday oh my gosh yo this is so
lit
yeah i can't wait you now have a credit
so whenever you get intro you can tell
the host hey will you just intro me as
the 100 joke contest winner
they'd be like what
you may have heard him on hot breath i
mean that's a real credit that's a real
crap
the reigning hot breath champion
and they think it's about halitosis
dude that is so cool oh and so yeah
leland said time for open mic night yes
i get a belt did i get a championship
belt for this you get you get money
and you get
a meme i mean you get like a winner's
image and then you get this interview
you're on the same podcast as like you
know jeff foxworthy i mean
by the way i love them you listen to all
of them everywhere every week i see i'm
a i'm for my day job i'm a mail carrier
so i listen to podcasts pretty much all
day long you every time you're
on my feed i never miss it let's go
oh you just made my heart smile there i
appreciate that nate
well yours is going to be on tomorrow
well all right i'll try to avoid that
one but
this is what it is though i like i like
to interview the winners just to
hopefully help people
realize oh maybe i could participate
maybe it's not as intimidating to
actually sit down and write 90 seconds
you know
well especially not after i mean
your your
class on comedy writing i mean i i
it's like my joke writing bible right
now like i i i got
i i've never i had never done any sort
of it's the first research at all i've
done on on
on joke writing and and it made perfect
sense to me so
i was excited to
start using all those techniques that
you taught me
i guess they're working i guess they
work
yeah thank i mean thanks nate yeah i
mean you know i've i've done a bunch of
research and experience on my own so
it's like i was trying to distill
something into
like a single class it's like with my
interviews i want to make
the interviews
like
the one-stop shop for like if someone
wants to learn about this comedian this
is the one place they go and i wanted
the same thing to be with all those
online classes and workshops so i'm i'm
thrilled to hear that they're working
you know i really appreciate you saying
that that makes that makes all of it
worth it right there
when i get the time and funds you know
i'm probably i'm gonna go through some
of those other classes you got on there
too like how to
how to mc i think is one of your classes
and yeah yeah yeah yeah
you might have heard of did you have a
crowd work went in there i'm not i
didn't yeah storytelling won a roasting
one
uh like show production podcasting yeah
i'll eventually make my way through all
of those i i really enjoy i really enjoy
your classes wow thank wow nate oh my
gosh i think there's gonna be a love
fest but i appreciate that
i'm so excited for you on thursday like
i think there's a lot of people that
listen
that
are thinking about getting on stage and
i know it's very gradual i mean even me
you know i went and watched several open
mics and then eventually worked my way
up to actually getting on stage what did
you've been doing a lot of learning and
researching but what has what did you do
to get over that hump and start actually
okay i'm gonna get on stage so like
what'd you do to make that transition
that's a big leap
well i just i mean i've been wanting to
do to get on stage for uh
a few months but
i i wasn't going to it's a the open mic
uh
at the comedy club of kansas city here
uh every thursday is uh three minutes so
you get three minutes and
you know it's the old adage you know you
may think three minutes doesn't seem
like that long but once you get up there
it can feel like an eternity so i just i
just
i was gonna make sure no matter what
that if i got up there for three minutes
that i was gonna have three minutes so i
i wasn't until until just this past week
i wasn't supremely confident that i had
i had definitely had three minutes that
i could go up there and do and and now
i'm in a position where
i'm i'm very confident that i probably
have a little bit more than three
minutes honestly probably have more like
four or five but
i know that i know that i'm not going to
get up there and run out of stuff to say
which is the most terrifying thing
for me yeah yeah for sure
i'm not afraid of that anymore so i'm
ready i'm ready to go up there and uh
you know
take it on
do you
have your set like you know what you're
gonna do like opening to closing you
have like your set
list they literally haven't memorized
it's in my head
it's gonna start
that that 90 seconds right there is the
first 90 seconds of it and then and then
i move into some other stuff about
religion and oklahoma and growing up in
oklahoma and stuff after that
so what we're hearing
the first set you're doing
is the set you did in this contest
the 90 seconds that you just saw will be
the first half of my first ever open mic
yeah gosh that's so exciting how did you
find the show did like
i think i just uh i got on spotify and
um
i just searched stand up comedy on spot
because i was looking i was looking for
podcasts that taught the art of any
podcast that taught the art of stand-up
comedy you know so i ran into this one i
got
you know like there's another one with
james madden and shulie they do this
podcast yeah
called thanks for coming out and all it
is is
professional comedians talking about the
worst times that they bombed and that's
equally terrifying and hilarious
that's that podcast
yeah just any podcast about the art of
stand up is is sort of what i was
looking for and i searched on spotify
and yours was one of the first ones that
popped up so
i don't think
oh it's working i was actually talking
about your open mic show but then you
were just gonna praise hot breath so i
just let you run with it
oh uh i'm sorry oh evelyn said that's
how she found the show too how cool
oh how did i find the open mic it's just
yeah i feel like some comics may be
listening and be like well how do i even
find a show well all i did was and this
was and this was a
something i was unsure about i just sort
of stumbled across it but i got on
facebook and i just typed in the search
in facebook kansas city comedians and
there's a literally a group uh just
called kansas city comedians and they
that one of the moderators of the group
they post a a chart and they update it
like every week or every two weeks and
it's just got a list of every open mic
in this area uh throughout the week and
the times and how much minute how many
minutes you get and what and any
rules that you might not know but yeah
they they have a little uh there's a
little a chart on kids on and i'm i'm
assuming most
cities that are relatively large have
something similar yeah you're
in atlanta something right so you
there's probably a facebook group called
atlanta
comedians or atlanta open micros or
whatever
and then that's how that's how i find
out about all there's a ton a way more
open mics around here than i ever knew
about i only knew about the one at the
comedy club in kansas city there's one
just about every day of the week
according to the chart that they post oh
yeah that's a good point is that a cat
yeah it's a cat
yeah no no joel that's my girlfriend
sexist
toxic male 1
that's her that's her signal that i've
been on that i've been on the computer
too long she starts mule like a cat mule
hilarious well we we won't take up too
much of your your cat's time
my dog
that's so cool i'm so excited to hear
how thursday goes man like
that that's that's such a huge step and
like there's i get i get asked a lot
like how
i want to get on stage but don't know
how or where to start or whatnot so it's
cool to see you like
in real time winning this contest and
now going to be performing on stage
yeah i'm not too
the the biggest worry for me was just
about like i said
not having enough stuff to say
but now that i do like being in front of
a crowd of people doesn't bother me too
much i spent a lot of time i spent a lot
of years in the marine corps talking to
big
big crowds of devil dogs you know i mean
um i was
for 10 years so whoa
[__] speaking in front of people
doesn't bother me
it's just that i don't want to look dumb
that's what
what are devil dogs uh marines that's
what they call marines that's what they
call marines yeah i'm sorry
no it's okay
okay
i didn't know that did someone else know
that in the chat i don't know i feel
like a bad american you're like devil
i'm like what are devil dogs you're like
you know the people that allow you to do
this silly show
you can
be on zoom on sundays
i'm sorry i feel like i i didn't mean to
be disrespectful there
no it's not disrespect man some people
don't know
like i just
i assume everybody knows because i grew
up in this environment yeah
from the military to comedy wow
how cool
yep
yeah it's something i've always wanted
to try i just never really had that
drive and a and plus
it's it's much funner it's much funner
to just say i could do that than to do
it
i don't know if it's much fun or it's
much easier it's much easier just to sit
back and go i could definitely do that
and then the difference between that and
then going out and doing it
um so
oh yeah it's always easy from afar it's
always like oh yeah that's not so bad
but it's actually doing it you know
the idea is the easy part
yeah i've always been sort of like a
backseat driver of comedy you know like
i just tell them i tell i tell them how
it's done but i'm just going to stay
back here
yeah yeah yeah yeah
now i'm taking the wheel joel i'm taking
the wheel and we're going 90.
yeah
fresh off this momentum you're right
dude you haven't even done comedy yet
and you just got your first paid gig
i mean
you may have peaked early there nate i
don't know maybe this
i'm actually retiring after this podcast
don't let it go to your head nate he's
gonna walk in the open mic do you know
who i am
oh man i love hearing that though dude
i'm so excited for you i'm excited to
hear how that open mic goes you're gonna
do great i'm hoping i'm hoping you know
what if i if i if i do great i'll get a
i'll get a hot breath uh
tattoo on my chest
right over your heart right over your
heart right there i would i would but i
already got oklahoma over my heart oh oh
i was looking at your tan line bro
that comes from being a mailman
hilarious
oh man oh and gary said maybe you're the
next comedy legend
i am in my own mind
yeah dude
oh that's so cool well i mean thank you
i mean congratulations first off it was
it was such a killer set
and it's always good to just see younger
up-and-coming comics competing in this
and it paying off
i appreciate it yeah i'm
i'm really pumped about it i felt good
about the set and and like i and chris
and jack obviously they were both great
as well
so it was
a good
competition yeah
see you guys next month yeah oh you're
going to do it again
i'm going to do it every month
i love it i love it
my goal is to bleed you drive these
hundred dollar checks
anything i can do to help i i will say
it probably took me years to make 100 in
common
so
you're ahead of the game already i don't
remember the first time i made 100 bucks
i remember i made the first time one of
my first paid gigs i got paid 25 to host
a restaurant show
in the hood of atlanta
and there was
i don't want to say who it was
but there's an atlanta comic
who um who's now very well known
but he bombed this night like
and it this was a i was a terrible host
i'm sure this was the first show my wife
ever came to as well it was called jr
crickets and it was on the south side
and all cachade for anyone who knows
atlanta off caccade
cacay road and
he bombed
really bad
but then
he sprit like it was so bad he like ran
out the back of the the club out the
back of the restaurant like he tried to
run his way out but it was double doors
and the one of the doors was locked
so
he bombs
tries to run out of the restaurant and
then runs right into a locked door
at least that i mean that must have got
a laugh right
hey yeah that did actually get a laugh
because it was so dramatic
that guy sucked but his finisher was
awesome
he left him laughing so he hit that door
and it was locked and then he ran out
the other the door next to it but like
so that was my first gig and that was 25
bucks and they paid me with a check
they paid me 25 with a check and i was
just like bruh really i'm gonna have to
like i have a paper trail of this
terrible gig i've done
i have to endorse this and like yeah
but you know now you're you made a
hundred bucks and you have to leave your
chair so
times are changing you young guns y'all
don't know the struggle
i feel like an old old head out here
uh well
i'm probably older than you to be honest
yeah i'm 34. i am 38. oh nice you look
good man white don't crack
we marble we don't crack we marble
i just get horrible tanks hmm
well is there anything else uh you would
like the world to know before we land
this plane
um
can i just uh plug my twitter yeah
do it
at real nate cosby at real nate cosby
that's where you want people to check
you out
and if you're hearing this tweet at him
let him know hey i heard you on hot
breath
that's why i love hearing that when like
i've had guests reach out to me of like
yo i did your show and then like a lot
of people reached out i love i love
hearing that the hot breath the verse
is just ouchia you know really
connecting with each other that's the
best
thank you so much joel for um
the whole contest the opportunity the
classes that you have set up like i said
i plan on going through all of them i
think they're rad and it's great
information for anybody who hasn't
signed up to for one of those classes
yet they should if you care if you want
if you have a modicum of interest about
writing in comedy or just doing stand-up
comedy i suggest you go check out jill's
classes
hotbreathmedia.com they're all there
nate thank you so much my friend and
congratulations well deserved yeah man
thank you all right have a good day
buddy
bye
all right we did it oh my gosh
oh and jack allen said what a great guy
top bloke i totally agree that was so
cool oh my gosh
and his first
open mic this thursday yo we gotta rally
around nate here we gotta
make sure we check in with them see how
the open mic went
that was fun oh my gosh
we'll have to check in with nate
see how that open might get and we'll
have to follow it up on the show
i'm sure people would love to know he's
never done it before
interesting
well i appreciate all for hanging out
and participating in this like nate said
you want to compete you know just join
one of those master classes that's
linked in the live chat right meow
pin to the top there hoppersmedia.com
oh dino said no one is going to try
slapping him on stage yeah
exactamundo
beautiful
this was a lot of fun y'all thank y'all
so much for hanging out seriously this
is so much fun to do
oh
bobby said great contest thanks joel
byers angel's on y'all
yeah i really appreciate y'all hanging
out spending your valuable time with us
congratulations to nate
i love you all so much
i'm gonna now
go back
and record the intro and outro for the
show because that intro
um
didn't go great
well i guess while i'm on here i could
do it
since y'all are hanging out here
i'll do it after i don't want to hold
you up
i don't want to hold you up
but go join
the comedy writing master class
competing next month
or
if you're in
if you're already in the competition
every month and you haven't been
submitting
make next month the one you submit to i
know it's hard trust me i try to get
myself to do them every month but not i
still don't submit every month you know
this month i had kovids so i think i had
a really good excuse but i've missed
other months just because time got away
from me and whatnot but
i really do want to make this contest a
place for
number one just
create a supportive and accountable
group
to write new jokes every single month
that's the whole goal of this contest so
yeah it's cool to get paid to be on the
podcast but it's the material is what's
actually going to level up your career
long term so
i'm hoping
that we'll see more and more people
participating because i know it's a lot
of effort but
it's a lot of work but it's worth it so
thank you all so much for hanging out
here
i'm gonna record this intro and outro
get this podcast scheduled
and then i'm planting some bulbs today i
know i'm planting bulbs
dahlias and
tulips bulbs
um
yeah
yeah yeah i was just trying to think if
there's anything else and then i thought
i heard my wife leaning in like is he
gonna roast me for wanting us to plant
stuff every day
but those of you that keep up with this
have been watching since those early
days
basically after every live stream i'm
like i gotta do yard work
because the early years it was cleaning
up everything and now we're planting
stuff again
so go forth with the old days my friends
i love you all so much oh bobby's
planting bulbs as well how fun
and then i'm going tonight to see my
buddy ben palmer he um
hilarious comedian who's gone viral on
tick tock and is now selling out
tours
based on his hilarious content i've
known this cat since the early days he
actually
he got slapped on stage before
chris rock i was at a gig where he got
slapped on stage one time
but if you're on tick tock his account
is palmer trolls and the same on
instagram but hilarious hilarious stuff
he does a lot of like funny prank calls
and trolling and stuff but super unique
super funny cat i'm going to go see him
tonight and then i'm going to interview
him
later this week while he's in atlanta
but
i say all that to say
i love you all so much thank you for
hanging out
i love you all congratulations to nate
great job jack and chris as well
and we'll see you on tuesday for our hot
breath live at 5 pm
bye y'all
oh thank you so much evelyn
sorry there's a slight delay between my
video and then the live stream so i'll
say something
and then it doesn't register until like
15 seconds later
um but thank y'all
yes have a good day out there everyone
angels on y'all angel's on y'all
[Music]
you